Okay, what's the difference when one is in remission versus no evidence of disease?
The positive attitude perspective, I don't like saying my cancer and no evidence
of disease, sounds better to me than remission.
If signature blood tests MRIs, et cetera, show no cancer, I do recognize our immune systems
are often killing cancer cells on a regular basis.
Well, I agree, it's I think whatever you want to say that helps you from an emotional
standpoint, you can call it whatever you want.
Be personally, if somebody says how's your cancer, I typically say, I feel like I'm in
full remission because I also don't want to be foolish and sometimes I am about, you
know, forgetting about my cancer, then just going back to a bad diet which I tend to do.
So I know I have to be cognizant of my weaknesses, so I keep that in the back of my mind that
I need to take better care of myself and diet is the thing that I struggle with from my
fleshly standpoint.
So I like to kind of remind myself that even though I don't really think about my cancer
on a daily basis like I used to because I don't have the symptoms anymore and because scans
did show, you know, your complete remission.
We also want to balance that with, you know, I've had patients come to me when they first
come to me, they said they were, you know, given no evidence of disease diagnosis by their
oncologist a year ago and now the cancer is back with a vengeance and it's spread all over
their body and the oncologist basically told them to call hospice.
That's happened.
That happens.
In our office, at least on a monthly basis, that we get a call of somebody in that situation
maybe even more frequently than that.
And I think it's sad that when you to give a person this false hope like you beat cancer,
it's gone.
Don't have to think about it anymore.
And then they go back to a bad lifestyle that got them there.
But in truth, maybe people in that, some people in that situation never made any lifestyle
changes.
Anyhow, they relied on the standards of care approach to get them into a state of remission,
which is great.
But you know, if you don't change what got you where you were, then, you know, it's going
to come, you know, you're going to be back to where you were again.
So whatever works with your mindset is what's important.
If you can stay on the straight and arrow and be eating well and doing the right things,
you know, sometimes the diagnosis of cancer pushed us to, then you could just say, I don't
have cancer anymore.
I have a lot of patients that just don't want to admit that they have cancer because they
don't want to put that in their mind.
They don't want to give the devil a foothold.
That's just fine.
We all have to think and use our mind correctly what's going to help us stay as healthy as possible
as well.